[Music]
okay we're here on the internet and
here's a question for you Donna is there
any reason that Supreme Court justices
should be present at the State of the
Union and is it a sign of disrespect if
they choose not to be
well mr. Scalia said that it was silly
to show up
mr. Thomas I'm sure that that's
bipartisan right he didn't show up for
bushy but that's correct he hasn't shown
up for a while I think in 2009 Clarence
Thomas showed up but over the last
couple yeah finally over the last couple
of years we've seen maybe four or five
Supreme Court justice did you know show
up at the State of Union ah I don't
think it's a sign of disrespect maybe
but definitely like an Constitution
about it right it's just a tradition
it's a tradition totally attrition well
we only Jefferson stopped giving State
of the Union addresses Washington gave
them an atom's gave them
Jefferson hated public speaking he also
thought it was to mark achill like the
king did Kings address so we didn't have
one from 1801 until 1913 I think Wilson
Wilson started yes and Wilson cuz he was
professor couldn't help the talk it is
just in the end there was and there was
some controversy a couple it was he last
year a couple years ago where the
president criticized the court and Alito
said not true right shook his head so
that there was some kind of bully mouth
it he did it wasn't like I showed up
like that was Joel's right right it is
funny the way people I think if you do
something long enough and it becomes
your tradition they think it is written
in stone it's same thing with religion
by the way because I heard lots of
people say well there's no rule that
says the Pope can't quit there's no rule
that says there's a Pope Jesus never
something about Pope's almost everything
in the Capel of the Catholic religion is
made up by the people who came after
they made up the whole thing as they
went along the Holy Ghost all that [ __ ]
hey Johnny man
yeah it seems like you have an issue
with religious yeah it just seems like I
I think I think you might be onto
something then pick up on okay um
Jamie how could the GOP better
communicate conservativism to younger
voters well I think that there's several
ways they can do it I think there's some
issues that the the GOP should steal for
instance the one that you might be in
favor of get out front on marijuana
decriminalization I would go far as
legalization McConnell seems to and I
think
but although hemp is not pot people
should realize you know I always say if
you think hemp is pod try to get high on
it you know yeah but but but is it no
but but hemp is a biological cousin of
pot it's still illegal yeah because
that's how freaked out we are about that
horrible drug pot but that is an amazing
step to me I mean I was shocked when I
saw that and I mean unfair both both
parties we really haven't addressed this
issue in any significant way true so if
the Republicans were bold which I don't
see this happening anytime soon on this
issue but if they if they were to step
out and take that issue you know that
that's something means something I think
to a lot of young voters bring in a lot
of voters yeah new voters you know
that's that's one pound one possible
outer-box to a long day voters right
show on the wrong day yeah what are you
worried for women I mean I would be in
support of that the Republican Party I
don't think they're awesome parties
opposed to equal pay for women they just
don't think they probably have to pass
legislation I think there's I mean you
could talk to conservatives no
legislation to they have binders motion
you have binders that's right
number Mitt Romney you could pay them in
marijuana and be very progressive
MIT wanted to hire women he just didn't
know any that was why he needed the
binders but I think a lot of people were
saying they wish that President Obama
had the binders full of women with his
recent cabinet picks the top State
Department and Treasury right there
having sex changes actually it is very
extreme I don't know why they're doing
it all right uh wrestling is being
removed from the Olympics Joel will you
miss it why is it yes this is my issue a
really good year have a big problem with
wrestling being removed from the
Olympics seriously if you take away I
can't believe I'm Nam yelling uh I'm
really mad about this it was one of the
basic sports of Olympics it's where it
started it is literally two guys were
wrestling and someone said let's judge
this and then you're like okay you'd run
as fast as you can then there's running
and then throw stuff that was the whole
Olympics and now and literally it
wakeboarding might take its place uh
what did I know wakeboarding kind of
hurt and I have never heard of that it's
where you kneel on a little surfboard
and you get towed by a boat and if that
they did it anything like the wake from
a boat that's where the yeah just like
waterskiing but on a little surfboard no
[ __ ] yeah but I mean if I remember my
laundry the Olympics began in 776 BC in
the city of Ellison Greek I'm Reming
this from Cornell in 1978 um that's a
lot of hemp but that's a lot oh geez
back in the Carter year yeah exactly I
mean this has a lot of history to it yes
it seems like a [ __ ] it should be
somehow protected it's kind of really
got rid of the Pope can resign they can
get rid of wrestler they've bribing the
Olympic Committee then as well yeah yeah
uh bunch of the other name that I've
John you've said James Monroe was the
only president who did not preside over
a time of deep partisan divide how did
he do this really the only one I think
so he let's put him in context James
Monroe sir from 1815 right 18 18 18 24
1925 25 elect an 18 and then
no in 16 and 18 16 18 17 to 18 right the
Monroe Doctrine 18 row debris it's all
coming back to me tonight there you go
it's all that's impressive it's ready he
was the the third produce the second
protege of Jefferson's to be president
he had three so Jefferson was in for two
terms Madison was in with two terms
Monroe for two terms then we had John
Quincy Adams and in Jackson and we get a
John you know everything I'm sorry sorry
I had bad just working through this no
keep work haven't asked about James
Monroe no in at least three hours uh so
I mean there's Van Buren
it's not that big that was a big moment
that was that was a great a great year
as I'm making this up the oh no no I
can't I can name all the presidents and
all this is just like yeah just so I
there was the era of good feelings and
what it has gonna start in about two
minutes what had happened what oh that
you're a good feeling yes I remember
yeah yeah were you the era where did you
go to high school oh those baptized at
the Vatican oh that's right you don't do
a thing
no they the Federalists had exploited it
imploded because they had tried to
secede from the union after Jefferson
bought Louisiana the first accession
movement was New England not the south
they wanted to break away because they
saw that the country was gonna move
further south and west and they were
gonna be excluded they wanted to join
either Nova Scotia or Britain again they
didn't like it that he bought Louisiana
they were like honey take that back
exactly they fell they're gonna be
outnumbered and they didn't like their
chances and that was instantly actually
Timothy Pickering started drafting
articles of secession and so they had
imploded and the war of 1812 had been a
victory so the Madison Jefferson forces
got credit for that and so there was
kind of no coherent opposition to what
Monroe represented at that point it's
not a hell of a lot different than where
we are in a way now where both political
forces essentially share the same
establishment kind of ideologies there
are differences obviously but it's
really an establishment party with two
wings is this on the test it's gonna be
yeah there's a you've already got a
real time would go more exciting edit an
ass building his guests are questions
right out of the show at hbo.com